John starts off this hour in Washington
DC hi John how are you I'm doing well
Dave how are you better than I deserve
sir how can I help so I recently had my
car totaled it was a 2008 and it was
worth about sixty sixty-five hundred
dollars and I got that as a total loss
settlement so I'm looking to get another
car and I've always gotten well I guess
at one time before I did get a used car
my net worth is not over a million
dollars so I have been looking at at
used cars but I went to a dealership and
they have some 2018 that they are trying
to get off of the lot you know with the
2009 teens that are that are have come
in so happens they rush in was yes my
question was do you
if those into the Year deals for what
have been new cars can be good enough to
get now be similar to used cars would
you could you buy a new car in that in
that case I wouldn't okay unless you're
Megan here right and you have a lot of
other money beside the 6500 yes I do
have money we will be you know paying
cash of course
so okay so whatever whatever we're
discussing here is cash yeah okay all
right so here's the thing you can do
whatever you want to your grown guy you
got the money okay the way I look at it
is this I look at data points with
people who are better than me in a space
have more experience than me in a space
and I say not how can I come right up to
the edge of that data but how can I be
way over the right of that data so that
I'm insured I get to be that example
would be I was blessed to get to get to
know mr. Tripathi that owned it started
chick-fil-a before his passing and his
wife Jean Dan his son is still a friend
okay and they were married I had the
time I time I first met them I think
they've been married 67 years and
obviously he was a highly successful
driven entrepreneur and so for Sharon I
get to get to sit with them even for 20
minutes and ask a couple that have been
that successful in business that's
successful spiritually that's successful
with their children that's successful in
their marriage 67 years what's the
secret
now once they tell me what the secret is
although it's not a secret we know that
right but once they tell me these are
the things I would do in other words mr.
Kathy if I want to be you when I grow up
marriage and spiritual work what would I
do give me give me ten minutes of wisdom
here I'm sitting at the feet of a great
man right then I ask him and then I
don't ask him and then take that and go
what's the least of that I can do no I
do right down the middle of that you
follow me yeah
and so what do what is the typical
millionaire do in the 10,000
millionaires that we studied for Chris
Hogan's book everyday millionaire
the typical millionaire has not bought a
new car in decades before they became a
millionaire
they didn't go well the eight teams look
like a good deal they just said we're
not putting our money in crap that goes
down in value and then scratch our head
and wonder why we're not millionaires
we're putting our money and things to go
up in value and cars go down in value
the largest thing we all buy the goes
down in value you can do whatever you
want to do but the data says the data
points the best practices the things you
want to emulate say stay away from
things that go down in value and not
stay right just barely away from them
stay way away from them so if you really
did some detailed research on cars the
best deal on a car is around two to
three years old with low miles it's
taken the most of the hit it's going to
take financially in value and it's got
the best technology available it's got
the best a lot of life left in it
because it's a you know three year old
car got 14,000 miles or something like
that
very low mile car and but the technology
is only three years old the things got
all the life left of a brand-new car in
it but it's already lost half of its
value and so you let someone else take
the butt-kicking on this stuff and you
go be rich and that's what we're talking
about here and so my point is not to
pick on you John but my point is it's
just a lesson for all of us is don't ask
what's the least I can do
and still barely win ask what hate how
fast can I get there I won't drive like
no one else so later I can drive like no
one else and that changes everything
then so but again you do whatever you
want to do we're not gonna be mad at you
either way
but that's that's where my guidelines
come from and that's where these
concepts come from it's what I stuck to
by the way now I buy brand new cars but
I'm a multi-millionaire and it's a very
very small percentage of my world today
but when we were broke we didn't buy new
cars we drove piece-of-crap
and and that then we weren't broke
anymore it was amazing so that's that's
answered your question sir thanks for
calling